in order to understand where we are
right now i think that we need to go all
the way back to 2020. but in order to
understand 2020 i think we need to take
a trip all the way back to 2008 2009 and
for those of you who remember the global
financial crisis what we saw was
many many financial organizations
brought to their knees they literally
thought that they were gonna go out of
business some of them did some of them
went bankrupt some of them were saved at
the last second but during that time
central bankers learned a brand new
playbook of quantitative easing and in
that situation we had emergency monetary
stimulus that was brought forward
asset prices during the summer of 08
sold off there was about a six-month
liquidity crisis there was fear and
uncertainty all over the place look at
an asset like gold it went down 30
percent
but of course once the central banks and
elected officials decided to step in
they were able to create loose monetary
policy they were able to stabilize those
asset prices and send them in the other
direction if you look at an asset like
gold it then went up and by 2011 hit an
all-time high
now of course that playbook was measured
in hundreds of billions of dollars of
monetary stimulus if you then fast
forward to january 2020 what we saw was
historically low unemployment about 3.4
percent the economy was rocking now
there were some early warning signs in
2019 things like inverted yield curves a
high degree of ceos that were leaving
their jobs and a number of other things
that said to people maybe we are towards
the late stages of the longest bull run
in history
but no one regardless of what claims
they make today
understood that a pandemic was on the
horizon
and so in march of 2020
we saw the first cases of the kovit 19
virus in the united states
because of the lack of knowledge around
that virus
and the good intentions to protect
american citizens the u.s government
both at the local state and federal
level ordered people to sit at home
government mandated lockdowns
as soon as those government-mandated
lockdowns started to be implemented
what we saw was the velocity of money in
the economy drastically dropped
when the velocity of money drops it
means that you i and everyone else we're
not spending money we're sitting at home
and so as that velocity of money drops
that means that businesses aren't
driving revenue
if businesses in the virtual world or in
a local economy aren't getting as much
revenue puts pressure on them and they
may actually have to lay people off
but also there was businesses that were
just outright shut down they were not
allowed to operate by the government
and so businesses began in the latter
half of march of 2020 to lay people off
we saw 6.6 million people file for
first-time unemployment claims multiple
weeks in a row
this was not a good situation
so we have the velocity of money down we
have people locked at home and we have
unemployment skyrocketing into the low
double digits
of course the federal reserve and
elected officials they look in their
toolbox and they say what can we do
short-term pain is growing acute and we
need to address it
the incentives for central bankers and
politicians is to always address the
short-term pain and worry about the
long-term pain later
and that's exactly what they did the
federal reserve stepped in with
trillions of dollars in concert with the
treasury and they began putting money in
every exotic corner of the financial
system
the fiscal policy
came as well and we saw trillions and
trillions of dollars either through
monetary or fiscal policy put into the
economy
well when you go and use stuff
money into an economy you can really
only do it two different ways
you can either have the federal reserve
go and buy assets be a persistent bidder
in the market
or you can send money directly to
businesses and individuals
the united states collectively decided
to do all of the above
along with also dropping the interest
rates all the way down to zero percent
this loose monetary policy this historic
monetary stimulus
ended up leading one of the fastest
recoveries from a definition of a
recession in history
we by summer time were already recovered
and we had an asset bubble brewing
from the summer of 2020
when stimulus checks were being mailed
directly to people when businesses were
getting bailouts with no equity or debt
requirements
and when there was zero percent interest
rates and there was a persistent bidder
in the market the federal reserve
we saw assets explode upwards
now around q3 of 2020 we started to see
sophisticated investors on wall street
talking about inflation that inflation
may be coming
the talking points from the central
bankers from people in positions of
power and influence and even the
mainstream media
was that inflation was not something to
worry about and if we did get a little
bit higher inflation it simply would be
transitory
then by about q1 and q2 of 2021
the talk of inflation started to get
louder we still were under five percent
inflation but you could feel that things
were changing
there was consumer spending trends that
were starting to show up there was
businesses producing earnings reports
with record profits and growth
and it felt like the kovid 19 problem
was slowly but being put behind us
fast forward to the summer of 2021 and
we saw inflation break five percent cpi
year-over-year growth 5.5 or more
since that point we have not seen below
5 inflation and in fact it's only
accelerated with the latest reading
showing 9.1
but even though inflation was over five
percent in june july august september
and october
the federal reserve kept interest rates
at zero percent and they were still
buying assets in the market as the
central bank continued their loose
monetary policy regime
and they continued to buy assets and
expand their balance sheet with what
eventually became a 10x increase from
2008 2009 to 20 21
we saw all asset prices grow to the moon
valuation metrics in the public market
exploded and we're obviously multiples
way above where we've historically seen
them
crypto currencies like bitcoin exploded
upwards and hit all-time high after
all-time high after all-time high
and other assets like real estate
continued to grow as well
finally in november the federal reserve
started to talk about nomas
we must address the problem
we cannot have a zero rate environment
and we cannot continue to buy assets in
the market
at that point some investors said i've
seen this movie before
when the fed pivots
you should subscribe to the old adage
don't fight the fed
and the federal reserve at first talked
tough from november of 2021 until march
of 2022.
they talked tough they said they were
going to do things
some people believed them and others
thought they were bluffing
finally starting around march we saw the
federal reserve start to hike interest
rates and make capital in the market
more expensive
they claimed that they were going to
start conducting quantitative tightening
and although they really haven't done
that yet they're at least thinking about
it or trying to start selling assets
as the federal reserve began to talk
tough and then eventually raise interest
rates and eventually will sell assets
off their balance sheet
we have seen asset prices across markets
crash
a 60 40 global portfolio is designed to
protect investors if stocks go up
bonds they might not go up as much
if bonds go up stocks might not go up as
much and so naturally having a
diversified 60 40 global portfolio
should give you the protection and good
times are bad
but that's not what we've seen
stocks bonds real estate various
commodities
cryptocurrencies and much else all
suffering at the hands of one big trade
with the federal reserve is in control
now the problem is that since march or
so as interest rates have risen
we have not seen inflation come down
instead what we've seen is that
inflation is actually accelerating
we breached eight percent and then in
june of 2022 the data shows 9.1 percent
growth
now that 9.1 headline number really
grabs people's attention it's
unsustainable for the average american
family
food at home is up 12 percent year over
year
gasoline is up 60 percent
if you look at the things that people
buy on a day-to-day basis they're much
more expensive than they were 12 months
ago
but that 9.1 headline percentage from
the cpi
is on top of the 5.4 last june
so if you were to go back to june of
2020
and then look today
the prices in the consumer index
are actually up double digits over a two
year period that is compound growth
of
inflation
and so naturally the federal reserve is
stuck with a really hard problem
if they continue to aggressively raise
interest rates with 50 and 75 basis
point hikes if they begin and
successfully continue to pursue
quantitative tightening creating those
tighter financial conditions
they may get inflation down
but maybe they won't
but either way they will be able to
destroy demand which is the whole
purpose of what they're doing
and they could push the united states
into a recession
now there's a lot of critics that say we
are not headed towards a recession just
look at all of the consumer behavior
spending is up
transactions are up the use of credit
hasn't exploded higher
the consumer is healthy the consumer is
spending money they're spending it on
experiences and travel we've seen that
in the recent bank earnings
but in q1 of 2022 there was a gdp
contraction
economists forecasters and mainstream
media thought that we were going to have
a positive gdp growth in q1
instead we got an annualized negative
1.4 percent initially it's now been
revised down even more
and so if we had q1 gdp contraction
and then if you look at something like
the atlanta fed now system
or gdp now system you can see that it's
predicting q2 is going to be a negative
gdp number as well
two straight quarters of negative gdp
growth
is a recession
and so whether consumers are acting like
we're in a recession or not
isn't actually the point
that we've got two consecutive quarters
of gdp contraction
there has been very few times in history
that the federal reserve is aggressively
hiking interest rates going into a
recession and the federal reserve
continues to stick with the talking
points that they're not done yet that
they're going to continue to hike those
interest rates they're going to continue
to pursue tighter financial conditions
if we have multiple quarters of gdp
contraction and we are raising interest
rates it's likely just to push us
further and further in the wrong
direction
but again
to lose lose hand because if the federal
reserve does not raise interest rates
they do not conduct that quantitative
tightening
inflation will only continue
most people point at that 9.1 percent
number from june of 2022 in the cpi and
they claim victory inflation will have
peak they claim
but as my friend darius dale over at 42
macro has pointed out
if you look at the trailing three months
of inflation growth and you annualize it
the real inflation rate right now is
accelerating it's actually over 10
and so naturally the federal reserve as
they've tightened those market
conditions
have not had an impact on inflation
inflation is getting worse at the same
time that they're tightening
that means that one of two things has to
occur either the federal reserve takes a
baseball bat to the market and they
continue to do everything in their power
to destroy demand to bring down that
inflation number which is now
compounding at a very high percentage
year over year
or
they wave the white flag
and they say we will not push the united
states of america into a deeper
recession
we simply are going to let inflation run
high for a period of time
a high inflation environment is bad news
and a deep recession is bad news as well
and as if this was not complex enough
what we see is that in a time of loose
monetary policy
where they were drastically increasing
the monetary supply
there was all sorts of disruptions to
the supply chain
you can think of this
on a supply demand equation
increasing the monetary supply and
handing it to the market into
individuals
drastically increases demand
in the market for consumer goods and
services
if demand is exploding the producers of
goods and services
naturally in a free market would
increase their production to meet that
demand
the problem is that the producers were
not able to increase production
because of supply chain disruptions
those supply chain disruptions whether
for goods or materials that are involved
in services
ended up constricting the production on
the supply side so we have demand
exploding from the consumer and we have
constraints on the supply side
that is a cocktail for a high
inflationary environment
now add in
in february and march of 2022
geopolitical conflict with russia
invading ukraine
all of a sudden that region which most
people in the american economy didn't
pay a lot of attention to
now they have to get up to speed
because there's double-digit percentage
of oil and natural gas in the globe
coming from that region wheat production
fertilizer and many other core
ingredients for everyday life
originating from the russia ukraine
region
now as geopolitical
sensitivities conflict and uncertainty
drastically increase
we see many many countries starting to
look around and say
houston we may have a problem
now of course you can put another filter
or overlay on this situation which is
that for the last couple of years we
have seen the esg narrative take hold
and there has been tons of pursuit of
virtue signaling it sounds good to say
that you care about the environment
regardless of whether the decisions
you're making
actually are good for your citizens your
society your economy and your population
now we see countries like germany which
have run around and shut down power
plants and claim that they won't pursue
nuclear
begging russia for more oil
we see the united states where we refuse
to build more nuclear power plants where
we refuse to drill for oil within our
own country
running off to saudi arabia to beg for
more oil
the esg narrative has been delivered a
death sentence it does not work in
practice
what it does
is it forces countries to give up on
energy independence
and it creates all sorts of manipulation
in the market price
of various commodities
because ultimately the esg narrative is
a form of market intervention
and when you have market intervention
you cannot have free markets
if you do not have free markets
you do not have efficiency
ultimately an entire generation is
learning that free markets are smarter
than economists they're smarter than
politicians
and they're smarter than uri
free markets solve problems
we need to return back to a free market
economy
the federal reserve today is faced with
a no-win situation
they allow inflation to run high we're
in trouble they raise interest rates
we're in trouble they cannot solve the
geopolitical conflict they cannot
address many of the esg concerns
they simply are in charge of monetary
policy
now what we are facing is either a
recession or high inflation
my guess is that the federal reserve
will waive the white flag there will be
a fed pivot at some point maybe before
the end of the year or maybe it leaks
into the beginning of next year
but at some point the federal reserve
will have to acknowledge
they cannot push the united states of
america deeper and deeper into a
recession
you simply may have to let inflation run
wild
now of course there's one last
complexity that usually gets lost in the
analysis of what's happening right now
midterm elections are on the horizon
if any of the local elections or any of
the public narrative is a sign
it looks like it's going to be a
bloodbath for those on the democratic
side
now of course that doesn't mean that the
right can't go ahead and make many
blunders between now and then but there
seems to be a wholesale rejection
of the esg and woke narrative across the
united states
and naturally
if you are the current administration if
you are the party that is in power you
feel the midterm elections are important
and one of the death sentences to head
into a midterm election
is with gasoline prices skyrocketing
with the average consumer experiencing
nine percent inflation
and also psychologically worried about a
potential recession
high inflation
does not equal good results for your
political party in a midterm election
but even worse a recession doesn't equal
good results either
and so
my guess is that when the president of
the united states calls the federal
reserve chairman jerome powell to his
office
it's kind of like the principal calling
a teacher in and saying
i want you to teach whatever you want in
your classroom
as long as you subscribe to my general
philosophy
and so naturally the central bank is
supposed to be independent supposed to
be predictable and reliable
but what we have learned over the last
two years is that it is none of the
above
we have seen presidents on both the
right and the left
go ahead and rail on the federal reserve
about what they should be doing
we've seen a lack of predictability and
a lack of reliability in the central
bank as well
how do we expect the average citizen or
the average business to plan
one two three four or five years in
advance
let alone 20 or 30. if the monetary
policy continues to change on what
appears to be a quarter to quarter basis
and if the economic environment can go
from good times to bad times to amazing
times to dire times all within a
two-year time span
if there is one lesson that we have
learned over the last hundred plus years
it is that free markets
solve problems
we do not need a system we're central
bankers and politicians continue to
intervene in the market
as the great economist milton friedman
once said
government should be a referee
not an active participant
the reason why that is so important
is because as friedman also said many
times the government solution
is just as bad as the problem itself
and so what we continue to watch play
out over and over and over again
for the last 15 years or so
is that the central bank step in they
mitigate short-term pain
that sounds great in the short term
but it creates long-term problems
those long-term problems end up being
more painful
for folks especially those most
vulnerable in our financial system
today we do not have just a wealth
inequality gap that wealth inequality
gap is getting worse and worse and we
should address it
but we also have a financial education
problem
the lack of financial education in the
united states of america should be a
national emergency
50
or so of all citizens in this country
have
zero investable assets
that means during times of high
inflation they are sitting there with
100 percent of their economic value and
their wealth
exposed to an invisible threat that is
eroding their purchasing power and
ultimately stealing that wealth from
them
if we simply were able to educate the
average citizen on financial principles
like personal finance
spending less than you make and ensuring
that you invest in investable assets
we could drastically improve their
situation over the long run and we can
help them protect themselves
which assets they invest in is less
important than simply explaining to them
that although your grandparents or your
great grandparents could save their way
to financial security you can no longer
do that by saving in any fiat currency
around the world
you have to become an investor
because the guarantee is that every
single fiat currency in the world will
continue to be debased
because we have a debt problem globally
in the united states debt to gdp is
around 130
globally it's more than 350 percent
the only way that countries can service
that debt
is to continue to debase their currency
so they can pay off the debt
with future devalued dollars
as you have seen
for years and years regardless of
republicans or democrats being in power
we continue to raise the debt ceiling
which is just code
for using your second credit card to pay
off your first
we cannot pay back the debt
and we are not growing gdp fast enough
to actually service that debt
and so naturally the incentive is to
devalue the currency to continue to take
on more and more debt
and to simply keep the game going
this spells for long-term problems the
only way to solve these problems is to
have a first principle solution
we can either drastically increase our
gdp growth or we can transition to money
not based on debt
as we watch the problem unfold
there is very little that you as an
individual can do
you will not be able to complain
influence or hold accountable those who
are making these decisions
most of them are not elected officials
they do not work for the american people
they simply are appointed by politicians
and there is very little accountability
that you yourself have
so naturally what you have to do is
focus on what you can control
no amount of complaining will change the
situation
you simply have to understand that we
are transitioning to a world
which is looking a lot like our past
where individual responsibility
and personal independence is incredibly
important
you need to make sure that you're
educated you need to take the time to
understand how the world actually works
how the economy and monetary policy
works
you need to understand that a strong
balance sheet and strong cash flow
allow for insurance in good or bad times
and you need to make sure that you're
prepared for the worst
although
it pays to be optimistic and you should
hope for the best
the worst is always around the corner
and making sure you're prepared is
incredibly important
unfortunately the analysis of the
federal reserve and various other
central banks around the world
is not good
the outlook is dire we continue to see
problems of inflation and recession
but you as an individual you have no
ability to change that
you simply need to learn
the timeless principles of personal
finance
make sure that you spend less than you
actually make
ensure that you can get out of debt as
quickly as possible
make sure that you've got some sort of
rainy day fund
make sure that you're able to invest in
great assets that you feel you can hold
for a very long period of time
and simply stay disciplined and patient
and allow those timeless investing
principles to play out year after year
after year
the economic situation
is not great
there's nothing that you're able to do
about it you can only control
your micro situation
the more the people realize that the
better off that you'll be
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time